how's it going reject nation greg and
john here today i was like you know what
we've been covering like a one division
video
pretty much daily maybe today we
shouldn't cover a one division video and
then uh
film theory goes ahead and drops how one
division will end and why it matters
and then of course seeing a bunch of
comments i'm like wow change of plans
of course we gotta check it out love
film theory if you guys haven't
subscribed to them
do it get them to 10 million subs let's
get going people
oh yeah and keep a lookout for our wanda
vision reaction for the next episode of
manana marvel's wand division is a
big hit on disney plus and highest rated
mcu production
ever which honestly can only mean one or
two things i didn't know that we've all
really started i had no idea
disney's been spending way too much on
fight scenes apparently what people
really want to watch is the avengers
picking out baby furniture
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theories
now in technicolor you know if you're
like me you've been glued to the tv
every friday to check out the new
episodes of marvel studios as wanda
vision
partly for the intrigue partly for the
memes but mostly to watch the two most
overpowered avengers do something other
than hanging back during battle so
hawkeye doesn't feel even more
clint go useless to his wife and tractor
already arrow man is out of his depth
but in all seriousness one division is
like my perfect show one that recreates
the tropes of classic television and
then twists them to create a meta
commentary on the medium while also
weaving together a compelling mystery
where no one has any idea what's going
on i think something's wrong
if the number of requests i've got to
cover this series is any indication lots
of people are feeling just as confused
as vision about what's really going on
here and since those heartless monsters
that disney are making us wait a whole
week in between episodes gave us some
time to work two things out
because not only one division's big
mysteries also it's a shocking twist for
the near future of the marvel cinematic
very curious to see if you're right
villain of one division and the next
phase of the mcu as wonderful is wanda
maximoff
yourself i've heard this dance don't
smash that dislike button all at once so
you can't smash that subscribe button to
help push this channel over 10 million
subscribers
shall we if you read the online theories
the prevailing thought is that the big
bad wand division is setting up is
mephisto
who is quite literally the marvel
equivalent of the devil he does largely
what the devil tends to do in stories
he makes deals with people and then
tries to trick him into selling their
soul
so why would the internet hive mind make
this huge leap that classic sitcoms
automatically lead to
santa himself no so why would the
internet hive mind make this huge leap
that confused
dramatically lead to satan himself well
lots of small things really first
there's wanda's neighborhood
who's always wearing a brooch and is
dressed in a witch costume in the
trailer
her name is agnes very close to ag
agatha harkness a character from the
comics who also always wears a broach
and is a witch and just so happens to be
a servant of mephisto
add to that the fact that she says this
the devil's in the details bev
that's not the only thing
during that episode's fake commercial
break take a look at the back of the
toaster if you flip the image vertically
it says
666 associated with
the devil and even what satan have we
never i've never been told that i
thought of that
damn really okay oh
damn you're right oh has not been
pointed out maybe new rockstars did at
some point
we didn't catch it we did we didn't
watch the first two yeah
darn it with the devil and even outside
of juan division we see the devil
starting to appear in other corners of
the mcu in the trailer for the disney
plus series location
of some kind with a stained glass window
that clearly depicts
the dark lord of all things now that one
is super weird and considering how
marvel's release calendar is looking
the only places it really makes sense
for the devil to be introduced is either
iron heart yeah
so there you have it
and moving forward will be the big bad
of phase
five but hey that's just a
that the big bad theory division is
setting up is mephisto except for one
thing
marvel knows how much we pour over this
stuff to find out what's going to happen
they do all kinds of witchcraft to
obscure the truth and make us buy into
false realities
from thor's missing eye and ragnarok to
thanos's infinity stones and in this
case
i think the mephisto easter eggs are
just that fun references
to misdirect suits really because adding
mephisto
into the story at this point is too
risky a narrative standpoint or not
wanting to get supernatural with it
nothing of the sort i think it's too
risky for one reason
china exactly that's exactly what i was
thinking
of like china does not like supernatural
horror at all considering how big marvel
is in china i was like i wonder if they
would
actually do that only because i'm glad
he's pointing that out you might suspect
is a huge
market for movies it's the second
largest in the world in fact by a large
margin but in order for your movie to
release in china it has to follow some
pretty harsh censorship rules for
instance did you know that iron man 3
had four extra minutes
inserted into it in order to get
released in china including an extra
scene where it suddenly turns into a
chinese medical drama
that is not nearly as jarring as the
moments when the film promotes tony
stark drinking chinese milk products
which were put in there to ease the
population's concern over milk tainted
with murder
really i had no idea about not to
release any movies that are critical of
the country's past or current political
regime and along with that is a ban
on ghosts or things of a supernatural
nature
for instance this ban resulted in the
censorship of the controversial film
babe pig in the city because the censor
had a policy against talking
animals granted marvel has certainly had
its fair share of luck with the chinese
sensor board in the past
endgame got a pass despite back to the
future being censored for its use of
time travel
but disney has recently run into issues
with china after the release of mulan
and disney plus is still struggling to
release in the country so storylines
that heavily adventure
the lord of the hee double hockey sticks
dimension would probably be a risk that
they're not willing to take right now
besides the more interesting narrative
here and the one that all the clues are
pointing to is that the real villain of
wand division and the thing that'll kick
off the entirety of phase
five is wanda herself as she rips holes
into the multiverse
either out of anger or grief don't
believe me it's easy to forget at this
point
when she started as a villain in
avengers age of ultron where she and her
twin brother pietro were super powered
henchmen for hydra
and since then she has been through a
lot
present when her parents were killed by
a stark industry mortar shell
if that wasn't bad enough she was then
trapped for days next to a second
undetonated stark bomb we were trapped
two days
every effort to save us every shift in
the bricks i think
the accident kind of forgot about it
remember that trying to start
to kill us by the end of the movie she
loses her brother and
her entire country of sokovia and it
doesn't get any better for her when she
becomes a good guy she's blamed for the
accident that leads to the passing of
the sokovia accords and causes avengers
civil war
which then forces her to live as an
outlaw she had to see her beloved vision
die
twice once by her very own hand in
infinity war
and then she gets dusted only to come
back and have everyone she's friends
with
the team like black widow and captain
america either gone or
dead in the when you see it yeah you see
it
you see from a real clip compilation
you're like
damn that's a lot of trouble she has had
a tough deal in this universe
i was aware but man when you really
pointed out in more detail you're like
wow it just keeps getting worse i guess
my only thing of why i
was maybe she won't be the actual is
because i kind of teased that with
episode four the way how that ends
like that's a little too early on to
tease it you know but hey you know i
mean it's still
still very plausible it's a conclusion i
have not
scratched out yet final scene of end
game she's aligned with
falcon it makes no sense she is alone at
this point in the series
i mean all of that is enough to knock
the fake russian accent out of anybody
you said we would destroy the avengers
well there are people who are expecting
me too you know we both made promises
see i forgot to tell you my wife is from
europe what is it the joker always says
it takes one bad day well
wanda has had bad decades so wanda is
definitely in a fragile state when we
last see her in endgame but
wanda's inner struggle between good and
evil isn't just evident in the mcu it's
inspired directly from her origins in
the marvel comics
there she and her brother quicksilver
were founding members of the og
x-men villains the brotherhood of evil
mutants and you know they're the bad
guys because they put it in their name
the brotherhood family business their
leader
magneto yeah that magneto
maybe it's not a professor
join the avengers in avengers numbers
there has been some back and forth in
comics like avengers 53 and
x-men 45. now obviously the mcu doesn't
follow the comics to the letter so why
does any of this matter
well because they very often go back to
the comics for inspiration and while
bond vision is indeed an original story
it seems to be taking its cues from
three
specific marvel story lines the vision
and the scarlet witch limited series
avengers disassembled
you can figure out how that one goes and
house of m all of which
tell very different but connected
stories with
one big thing in common they all had
dark plot twists involving
reality not being what it seems and
wanda
being the cause at first glance vision
and the scarlet witch seems to be the
most similar to wand division in that
it's a fun sort of marvel story mostly
about the characters trying to live
normal lives in the suburbs including
wanda using her scarlet witch powers to
conceive her twin sons
tommy and billy sound familiar
yeah that's what happened in the episode
even though this quirky 80s miniseries
is a mostly happy story it gets an
unexpectedly dark conclusion in the
pages of west coast avengers a few years
later
it's revealed that billy and tommy
didn't actually
exist no really in a twist worthy of the
mid-tier m night shyamalan movie
it turns out billy and tommy are
illusions that wanda willed into
existence from her own subconscious
without ever
realizing it i know right how would that
work
you know how in the movies they never
really explain what wanda's powers are
and they don't really make a whole lot
of sense
it's kind of like the comics initially
yeah this time the simple version is
that she can alter probability in the
nature of reality itself
so basically she's not so much throwing
cars at your face as she is
creating a new reality wherein cars are
now on top of your face
anyway the whole i believe baby thing
was arranged by mephisto and a guy named
master pandemonium whose name sounds a
lot like the opening band for a mega
death concert and who it's worth noting
literally had babies for hands yeah i
know she's placed you can imagine
finding out your entire reality
and your children was a lie created in
your own subconscious it's gonna be kind
of traumatic
so every memory that was related to
tommy and billy gets erased from wanda's
memory never to be mentioned again but
then 20 years later in the massive
end of an era reboot event avengers
disassembled marvel decides
hey remember that time you thought you
had twins but you didn't because would
be as good
as any for the scarlet witch to lose her
mind so hard she nearly destroys the
avengers
in disassembled the avengers are
systematically disgusting
reappearances by some of their worst
enemies nearly all of which turn out to
be
illusions or psychic manipulations
caused by the scarlet witch's reality
changing powers
the whole thing forces them to get a new
clubhouse let wolverine join the crew
and ultimately reboot the issue
numbering so it was mostly an excuse to
shake up the lineup and redecorate but
it was a huge
deal in terms of redefining wanda as one
of the most powerful characters in the
marvel comics universe
after that came house of m which gave
her powers yet another frightening
dimension
literally when it's revealed that wanda
can do more than just change her own
reality she can create an
entirely new one in house of m she traps
the entire marvel universe in an
alternate version of itself where her
brother is alive again
and everyone who is still mad at her
from the last thing so
you know like a lot of people would
hopefully forget reality because they
suddenly had new lives based on their
greatest wishes coming true
spoiler alert doesn't work not a great
point leading to her
iconic line no more mutants where she
erases all mutant powers from existence
more or less it's a bit of an
oversimplification but that's the broad
strokes so already i bet you could start
seeing a lot of parallels here
a storyline about wanda and vision
living a perfect suburban life and
having two kids under mysterious
circumstances
getting some [ __ ] vibes there her
rewinding the show to rewrite how events
proceed when she doesn't like the
direction things are going
no
it shows that she has control over this
world her getting mad and eating people
out of sitcom land when things just
become a bit too real
it tells us that she has created
intentionally or otherwise an
alternate reality inside of this bubble
a perfect world where she can exist
alongside her dead robot lover and her
make-believe children
is that why the other characters are so
afraid of her are they prisoners trapped
inside of one division's alternate
reality the same way that the entire
marvel universe was trapped in the house
future matpat jumping in here who knew
episode four
would reveal quite so much kind of sucks
when your episodes take two weeks to
produce means that you're working with
three months
of information
gotta cross your fingers and hope it
doesn't blow too many things up anyway
uh this last point actually seems to be
confirmed in this latest episode we see
them go through
person by person showing that the cast
of the show are
townsfolk that are trapped in this
reality all except for one notable
exception who goes unnamed there was no
mention of
agnes suspicious i think so a key part
of the
storyline from the comics is that wanda
doesn't necessarily turn evil in them
it's just that when she loses control of
her subconscious it sometimes goes to
bad places
and does bad things so it's entirely
possible that while she is the one
controlling things in wand division
she's not
actually controlling them herself she's
not aware
that she's the one controlling them she
might be unconscious or
sedated or even in a coma i mean think
about this in psychoanalytic dream
theory of the type popularized by
sigmund freud the subconscious mind
rearranges seemingly unrelated images
and ideas into symbolically recognizable
new forms which we then recall
as dreams in our subconscious like say a
traumatic memory about a ticking stark
time bomb becoming a creepy ticking
stark toaster
because yeah i mean a lot of us have
picked up on the whole thing with the
commercials
yeah being some of the most obvious
hints about her trauma
damn i was the toaster thing never made
sense to me
yeah yeah oh i believe that for sure
and to make that potentially both a
mislead and also
a huge clue i think is just expert
brilliant
yes brilliant top and bottom heating
elements can handle anything
it's a star toaster yeah the red lights
by stark industries hear that suspicious
ticking of the toaster listen again
like a bomb or a dead knee top and
bottom heating elements can happen oh
never mind no i'm
[Music]
and this ominous flashing light that my
friends is no toaster
that is the ticking time bomb of
childhood trauma we wait for two days
for tony stark
to kill us then there's the commercial
in episode three about soap which is a
reference to agent coulson's theories
about
hydra using soap as a mind control
device
just went up on patreon this morning
hydra loads it up with chemicals
it seeps into our bloodstream and plants
false memories into our brains
they want us to believe this is a
magical place i make my own soap now
even the black and white palette could
be wanda's subconscious calling back to
vision's death in infinity war
dude great i would not have put this
together oh
wow oh considering how intentional every
choice seems to be
in almost every frame of this show
everything we've heard it's like the
most
reaching one but i could also see that
being a very intentional call
especially on top of all these other
details his whole body turned monochrome
which might just cause her subconscious
to associate the black and white
aesthetic of old tv with the last memory
of that person being dreamed back to
life
now that is meta hey future matpat again
this is another one of those things
that's nearly confirmed in episode four
after wanda is reminded of the reality
outside of her sitcom bubble
zombie vision in his real dead
again he's in monochrome am i the only
one thinking that she may just be
puppeteering the dead body of her
boyfriend
because if so that would be awesome in
short undeniable truth here is that
vision is dead
and there's a high likelihood that the
children aren't real or
if they are they're going to be taken
from her for the children
track dies and the retro clothes go away
at the end of the series which you know
they're going to
she's going to be left alone which means
this series is going to end with one
very unhappy very powerful witch running
loose in the mcu who now's unlocked the
ability to make
reality bend the knee is there a doctor
in the house perhaps a
master of the mystic in case you forgot
elizabeth olsen
is scheduled to play scarlet witch again
in dr strange in the multiverse of
madness in early 2022
but they never said she was one of the
good guys olson
is also starting to talk about rumors
that she might just pop up in the third
spider-man movie
you know the one that's also supposed to
be dealing with alternate universes
coming together also said to feature a
previously confirmed guest appearance by
doctor strange
and the one that's set to hit theaters
only three months before
multiverse of madness multiverse madness
man that is such a stupid name it's it's
like
really cheesy like awkwardly cheesy wait
a minute
multiverse of madness
if you ask me it looks like marvel's
newest mom is likely to end one division
ripping open reality in an attempt to
wait a minute i mean it's cool
fun cool it gets you excited initially
but that might not it's a little i'll
i'll roll with it for now we'll see how
the movie goes
ripping open reality in an attempt to
reclaim her happiness and
maybe even her kids with the rest of
phase 5 needing to sort it all out
and by the end disney gets to keep who
they like they get to lose who they
don't and they get an excuse to
introduce the x-men
without breaking the established
continuity of all the movies that came
before
no more mutants more like bring on the
mutants all it takes is for mom to go a
little bit mad
but wait future matpat here to chime in
one final time
all of this would actually be a pretty
bad look for disney
their first female hero black widow is
like the first
major character to get killed off in
these movies and then their second one
turns evil because
babies it's not a good look for him and
rewatching these episodes with number
four now in consideration
i think we're actually going to have
ourselves a scapegoat i do
think everything that i said in today's
theory is still going to wind up being
true but i think that there's one final
layer to all
someone is actually going to be revealed
to be using
wanda throughout this whole thing in the
comics
and the hexagons are the things to prove
it if you are paying attention to the
first three episodes
damn hexagons never thought so much
about geometry this way
outright making question number one why
hexagons and
well sure the mine stone was technically
a hexagon
the real easter egg that solves this is
right here
episode four seconds the new director of
sword has his diplomas on the wall
in a strange hexagon pattern that
matches
wanda's reality bubble every other
hexagon has been created within wanda's
reality but
this one is in the actual world with no
other reason of being put there
except to act as a clue to us the viewer
i mean
why spend so much time at sword
headquarters why
introduce this new character my guess is
that wanda has been to this
office and that the hexagons might be
her subconscious reacting to a memory of
being
in that director's room another it comes
from the difference between the comic
sword organization that we see hinted
throughout various symbols in the series
and the mcu sword
you see both titles are backronyms but
while the comic sword is named
sentient world observation and response
department the sword in the mcu is
ominously named
sentient weapon observation and response
division
this title indicates that rather than
dealing with intergalactic threats the
mcu sword is interested in sentient
weapons and how to deal with them
human weapons that have gone out of
control weapons
like wanda we even have this out of
place line shoved in there
it also says observation and response on
that door it's not creation
this line is meant to clue us in that
these people have made weapons in the
past
and it looks like the director might be
in the process of doing it again
because consider this if wanda's kids
are in fact
if this whole simulation is somehow
orchestrated by sword
for the children and they're taken from
her we have ourselves
truly the first characters actually born
with superpowers in this universe
they would be the first ever
wait a minute i'm a little bit confused
on the theory part here with the end
with uh director hayward so they're
trying to
contain wanda like they consider her a
threat the thing about the
tommy and billy being the first mutants
are they
trying to did are they aware that they
can be like first born mutants
ever because they'd be aware of the
possibility that she could bring these
into existence or something
yeah because if they are in fact real
they're not just some imaginative thing
they would be
the first mutants ever yeah you know
because they were born with powers
as opposed to being given powers later
on or had something done to them where
they got powers
ah that was cool i mean i never even
thought about that that if they are real
they would technically be the first
mutants
yeah yeah and then it just makes you
wonder how much awareness you know they
truly have a sword about what's going on
yes
and what her capability for bringing
that kind of you know life to bear and
who would know how to deal with mutants
professor rex
professor the most qualified guys
hey there all you hep cats yes you
watching this video have you considered
smacking that subscriber you sure it's
the swellest thing that'll keep you
smartest on the block or if you want
another theory about phase five of the
mcu watch out how
thor might be the one to turn evil in
the cosmic universe
we did react to that subscribe to them
guys click that notification bell hit
the like button check them out you can
do the same thing for us
man that was great that was amazing yeah
that was amazing it's like a lot of
what we've heard i wonder if them and
you rock stars are friends
because they're collaborating there is a
good amount where i'm like well we've
heard a lot of this before
i mean like some of it from just our own
conclusion a lot of it
from like watching a lot of new rock
stars there were times where i'm like
okay i've heard this from you rock stars
but then they go to further elaborate
more then i'm like oh damn that's even
more of an additional
thought on top of what we've heard
before that just goes to further drive
that point home
i do think they make a really solid
point when it comes to like china
that was my main concern of like would
they do that just because of china that
was that
that was a thought of mine all things
being said i don't think wanda would go
full batty i just feel like she would
land them in a position where she's done
some bad
things yeah they need to correct but i
don't think she'd become like full-on
villain she doesn't seem to have
malicious intent
all right guys well film theory what you
guys think of their video leave your
thoughts down below last but not least
gene the jeter just wanted to shout you
out real quick and say what's up
recently he sent me a couple voice
messages and i'm so glad that instagram
has finally updated itself
so i can hear your smooth velvet pipes
gene is got a little bit of sequel
franchise opportunities opening up
himself
as he is getting ready to follow up his
book
the craigslist model which i am now 20
pages into and when you see how this
book is written
in one day you're going to realize how
unimpressive your feet in about an hour
and a half
guys you're going to want to pick i was
like a week ago when i did that yeah you
did yeah you really should
two weeks ago i'm doing it incrementally
and you can
too it reads like a play or like poetry
sub to ego is the name of the the sequel
so you're going to want to catch up with
roxanne and slade
and uh gene she's an all-around good guy
i'm glad that you're at least doing your
best to stay safe i know a lot of people
around you have had
it which shall not be named and you've
been doing your best to stay locked down
so
keep safe and uh we'll talk soon much
love buddy
thank you buddy
[Music]
you